This morning, the Bud Light boycott,
the one taking sales
by more than 28%
over the last four weeks while the brands
the beer brand's
partnership
with the transgender influence
that sparked their culture war
and can be felt
across the country
and especially in Nashville
where the company
is facing backlash from both sides.
CNN's Ryan Young reports
A culture war is brewing over Bud Light,
dividing beer drinkers
as much as the country is itself.
Unlike anything I've ever seen,
I don't get it.
If you drink Bud Light,
Miller Lite, Coors Light,
it doesn't matter
if you don't
like what somebody's selling.
Just don't go there.
Sobbing
but heard about everything
that goes on in the world.
I celebrated my day three 65.
A womanhood.
The brouhaha stems from Bud Light
Short-Lived partnership
with transgender influencer Dylan Mulvany
Love ya.
The fury from the right enough
to dethrone Bud
Light as the bestselling beer in America
for the first time in two decades.
The controversy
has taken center stage in Nashville,
where two of country music's
biggest stars, Garth Brooks and Kid Rock,
have bars
just steps away
from each other on Broadway.
What's fascinating to me
is that right here
on Broadway in
Nashville, Tennessee, the culture wars
have come down to two big personalities
in this town.
It illustrates
the way the whole country
is responding
to the transgender acceptance.
Garth Brooks
says he plans
to carry the beer at his yet to open bar
I'm a bar owner now.
Are we going to have
the most popular beers in the thing?
Yes, I get it.
Everybody's got their opinions.
But inclusion is always going to be me.
A block down Broadway.
Kid Rock made his feelings known
when he posted this video shooting up
cases of Bud Light
Despite the online
bravado and talk of a boycott,
Bud Light was available
when CNN stopped in recently.
It is not clear
if the band had been lifted
or if there ever had
been one to begin with.
Nashville marketing
executive Bill Fletcher
says the whole country
seems to be engaging
in the same heated conversation
with Kid Rock.
You have this
dark, angry finger pointing,
shooting a gun at a Bud Light can.
And Garth Brooks is is hey,
I love everybody.
And openness and acceptance.
And I think it's what
you seen in the country
going back to African Americans,
to gay people when that's transgender
here on Broadway.
We're fans
from all around the world
come to maybe
listen some music and drink some beer.
This Bud Light controversy
has left a bad taste
and a lot of fans mouths.
It's quite simple.
People just don't want to shove
down their throat
no Bud Light
because it's like I have grandchildren.
We don't need to put that
in the young kids heads
in Chicago at
Two Beers
Tavern, a bar
that caters to mostly gay patrons
they also feel strongly
about not serving Bud Light any more.
But for the opposite reason,
they believe the brand
left Dylan Mulvany alone on an island
to face a mountain of hate.
To be a true
ally means
that you don't
push us behind the scenes and say,
We're going to give you some money,
but I really don't want you to be front
and center or public.
But in some Nashville
bars, the backlash against Bud
Light was hardly felt.
We had one guy
who said, I refuse to drink that anymore.
One guy
and everybody else in the bar
kind of rolled their eyes at him,
and there were plenty of bar
hoppers on Broadway
who were simply ready to move on.
Let's move on and let's party.
We're in Nashville.
Are you not bothered at all
by this Bud Light controversy like that?
No, not at all.
I don't get it, but I go
Well,
you heard that
she didn't
really give me care about this.
Look, sometimes you do these stories
and people don't want to talk.
People were lining up to talk about
but like this really has impacted
their their psyche.
28% of sales have been knocked off.
So this was a conversation
that we were more
than willing to have
with a lot of people.
I can tell you
there was a lot more on
the cutting room floor
because people had a voice.
They had concerns.
We even saw people
tell others to stop drinking Bud Light
while we were out
and about in those bars.
It was quite fascinating to watch
and the bright, young, great reporting.
Great piece. Thanks. Thank you.